This family is on the brink of civil war. On September 18th, Mobland, the hit original series is back on Paramount Plus. We are the Harrogans. Don't know the net? And Google us. From the underworld of Guy Ritchie. Do you want to step up the ladder? I won't come at dead. Starring Tom Hardy, Pierce Brosnan, and Helen Mirren.
这个家庭正处于内战的边缘。9月18日，派拉蒙流媒体（Paramount Plus）的热门原创剧集《莫布兰》（Mobland）回归。我们是哈罗根一家。不知道这个网？去谷歌搜一下。来自盖·里奇的黑社会。你想步步高升吗？我可不会死。由汤姆·哈迪、皮尔斯·布鲁斯南和海伦·米伦主演。
Do I have to do everything myself? You want to want! I'll give you a... Mopland. New season hits September 18th on Paramount Plus. On the 6th of July, 83 BC, the largest and holiest building in Rome was struck by lightning. The ancient temple of Jupiter loomed on the summit of the Capitoline hill. Here, beneath the ceiling, sheathed in gold, amid trophies of statues and shields. The guardian of Rome had his shrine. But now Jupiter had decided to destroy his temple with a thunderbolt.
难道什么事都得我亲力亲为吗？你想要就得去争取！我会给你一个……莫布兰。新一季将于9月18日在派拉蒙流媒体上线。公元前83年7月6日，罗马最大、最神圣的建筑被闪电击中。古老的朱庇特神庙矗立在卡比托利欧山的山顶。在这里，在镀金的天花板下，在雕像和盾牌的战利品中，罗马的守护神拥有他的神龛。但现在，朱庇特决定用雷电摧毁他的神庙。
What was the cause of the gods' anger? As the crowds gathered to watch the disaster, the flames billowed, sparks, and smoke across the forum. This was the heart of Rome, stretching all the way from the capital, Hill of the Gods, to the Palatine, Hill of Power. The Forum, along with the Circus Maximus, was one of two open spaces within the city walls, where Rome's citizens could mix freely.
众神愤怒的原因是什么？当人群聚集观看这场灾难时，火焰、火花和浓烟在广场上翻滚。这是罗马的心脏，从众神之山卡比托利欧山一直延伸到权力之山帕拉蒂尼山。广场与大竞技场一样，是城墙内仅有的两个开放空间之一，罗马公民可以在这里自由交流。
Here was the Comitium, where citizens gathered to hear orators address them from the rostra, the curved speaker's platform made from the prows of long-ago captured ships. Immediately adjacent to it was the Curia, where the Senate met, and a little to itself the temple of Castor and Pollux, where the assemblies were summoned to debate and vote on laws. Along this axis of buildings and open spaces lay the great theatre of the Republic's political life. Rome's most potent expression of her citizens' liberties and values.
这里是公民大会堂，公民们聚集在这里，听演说家从讲坛上发表讲话，讲坛是由很久以前缴获的船只的船头制成的弧形平台。紧邻它的是元老院所在地库里亚，稍远一点是卡斯托尔和波吕克斯神庙，公民大会在那里被召集起来辩论和投票表决法律。沿着这条建筑和开放空间的轴线，坐落着共和国政治生活的伟大剧场。这是罗马公民自由和价值观最强有力的表达。
All the more portentous then, that as the fire on the capital raged, it died the forum below it, angry red. Red the colour of Mars, the god of war and bloodshed. So, if you think that was a very melodramatic reading, charged with the sort of port wine-soaked tones of one of London's greatest clubmen, you would be right. That was from Rubicon by our very own Tom Holland, describing an ominous moment in the descent of the Roman Republic into its first civil war. The gods are angry, but Tom, with whom? Well, I mean, that is the question, isn't it? Because we left you last time.
因此，当卡比托利欧山上的大火肆虐时，它将下方的广场染成了愤怒的红色，这显得更加不祥。红色是战神和流血之神玛尔斯的颜色。所以，如果你认为这段朗读非常夸张，充满了伦敦最伟大的俱乐部成员那种沉浸在波特酒中的语调，那你是对的。这段话出自我们自己的汤姆·霍兰德所著的《卢比孔河》，描述了罗马共和国陷入第一次内战时的一个不祥时刻。众神愤怒了，但汤姆，是对谁愤怒呢？嗯，我的意思是，这正是问题所在，不是吗？因为我们上次讲到……
with the Republic in the shadow of two great patrician strong men. And the first of these is Sulla, a man who is at once completely charming and utterly sinister. He's very cultured. He's unbelievably brutal. He is a conservative, but he is also a revolutionary because he is the first man ever to lead a Roman army on Rome. So Sulla had led his army on Rome in 88 BC and in the intervening years. So between his march on Rome and the burning of the Temple of Jupiter on the capital, he has achieved remarkable things.
共和国处于两位伟大的贵族强人的阴影之下。第一位是苏拉，一个既完全迷人又极其阴险的人。他非常有教养。他极其残忍。他是一位保守派，但他也是一位革命者，因为他是历史上第一个带领罗马军队进攻罗马的人。所以，苏拉在公元前88年带领他的军队进攻罗马，而在随后的几年里，也就是在他进军罗马和卡比托利欧山上的朱庇特神庙被烧毁之间，他取得了非凡的成就。
So he has taken the water Mithridates, who was this bold and ruthless and vindictive king who had conquered the Roman province of Asia and invaded Greece. And in only three years, Sala had reversed all of Mithridates, He had brought Greece and the province of Asia once again to acknowledge the might of Rome, and Mithridates had retreated to within his own borders, and he was obliged to accept Roman weapons inspectors to make sure that he wasn't rebuilding his offensive capabilities. And so you would think that back in Rome, the news of Sulla's triumphs would be greeted with praise and with thanksgiving and with all kinds of celebrations, but not a bit of it. Because back
他击败了米特里达梯，那个大胆、无情且怀恨在心的国王，他征服了罗马的亚洲行省并入侵了希腊。仅仅用了三年时间，苏拉就扭转了米特里达梯的所有战果。他让希腊和亚洲行省再次承认了罗马的威力，米特里达梯被迫退回自己的边界，并不得不接受罗马的武器检查员，以确保他没有重建进攻能力。所以你可能会认为，在罗马，苏拉凯旋的消息会受到赞美、感恩和各种庆祝活动的欢迎，但事实并非如此。因为回到……
in Rome, the city is ruled by Sulla's enemies. And they have responded to Sulla's great feats by declaring him a public enemy and raising his house and running his family and friends out of the city. And Sulla is not happy about this. You know, this is not a man that you offend recklessly. And in 84 he had written a letter to the Senate, and Ari and the Greek historian describes what he said. He said he would be back very soon to take his vengeance on behalf of all those who had been wronged and on behalf of Rome itself upon the guilty men. So a very, very ominous threat. Oh, a chilling warning. So Sulla has lots of enemies, but there's one in particular, isn't there? Particularly formidable, but also the particular object of his hatred and
罗马，这座城市由苏拉的敌人统治。他们对苏拉的伟大功绩做出的回应是宣布他为公敌，拆毁他的房子，并将他的家人和朋友赶出城外。苏拉对此并不高兴。你知道，这不是一个你可以鲁莽冒犯的人。在公元前84年，他写了一封信给元老院，希腊历史学家阿庇安描述了信的内容。他说他很快就会回来，代表所有受过委屈的人，代表罗马本身，向那些有罪的人复仇。这是一个非常、非常不祥的威胁。哦，一个令人不寒而栗的警告。所以苏拉有很多敌人，但其中有一个特别的，不是吗？特别强大，但也特别成为他仇恨的对象，而且……
for completely understandable reasons. Now, we talked about him last time. This is a man called Sinha, who is very able, very ruthless, very opportunistic, who is, you know, just as dedicated to the pursuit of victory and total defeat of his opponent as Sulla is. And remind us about Sinha. So Sinha, he'd been elected as consul, hadn't he, just before. Sulla went off to fight his war. And Sulla had said, you've got to swear an oath that you won't attack me. Yeah. Sinha had said, fine.
原因完全可以理解。我们上次谈到过他。这个人叫秦纳，他非常有能力，非常无情，非常投机，他和你一样，致力于追求胜利和彻底击败对手，就像苏拉一样。提醒我们一下关于秦纳的事。秦纳，他在苏拉去打仗之前刚被选为执政官，对吧？苏拉曾说，你必须发誓不攻击我。是的。秦纳说，没问题。
And then the moment Sulla went, he stabbed Sulla in the back. And basically, for the past three years, while Sulla's been away fighting Mithridates, Sina has been the dominant figure in Roman politics. And he had upheld his power in a completely unconstitutional manner by holding consulship after consulship after consulship in succession. And by 84 BC, when Sulla sent that threatening letter, Sinha was onto his fourth consecutive consulship. And this is basically the closest to being ruled by a permanent autocrat that the Roman
然后苏拉一走，他就从背后捅了苏拉一刀。基本上，在过去三年里，当苏拉在外与米特里达梯作战时，秦纳一直是罗马政治中的主导人物。他以完全违宪的方式维持着自己的权力，连续担任了一届又一届的执政官。到了公元前84年，当苏拉发出那封威胁信时，秦纳已经进入了他的第四个连续执政官任期。这基本上是罗马共和国迄今为止经历过的最接近永久独裁者统治的状态。
Republic has yet experienced. So again, a kind of ominous portent, perhaps, of the way that things are going. However, as Sinha prepares for Sulla's return, I mean, he's not alone because he's dependent for his position of authority on the support of a quite sizable faction. And these are the Marians, the followers of Gaius Marius, who for decades had been Rome's most successful and celebrated general until Sulla had replaced him. And Marius and Sulla had ended up as very, very bitter rivals. Now, Marius himself by this point is dead. He'd had this kind of massive bender and essentially kind of collapsed of overindulgence, very elderly by this point, kind of in 70,
所以这又是一个不祥的预兆，也许是事情发展方向的预兆。然而，当秦纳为苏拉的回归做准备时，他并不孤单，因为他的权威地位依赖于一个相当庞大的派系的支持。这些人是马略派，即盖乌斯·马略的追随者，在苏拉取代他之前，马略几十年来一直是罗马最成功、最著名的将军。马略和苏拉最终成了非常、非常痛苦的竞争对手。现在，马略本人此时已经去世了。他当时年纪很大，基本上因为过度放纵而崩溃，大概是在70岁左右，
I think. But he has, so in the mafia sense, he has left his family, his familiar. He has a lot of supporters, a lot of people who have always backed Marius and have grown very rich off backing him. And just because Marius himself has gone doesn't mean that his familia is now dead. And the guy who has inherited the leadership of this familia is the son of Marius, who by 84 is 26 years old. But by virtue of being the head of this kind of Marion clan is already a very serious player in Roman politics, even though he hasn't as yet held any magistracies at all. And we mentioned him, we described him last time he's very good looking, he's a playboy, and he's eager to show himself his father's son.
我想。但他留下了他的家族。他有很多支持者，很多一直支持马略并因支持他而变得非常富有的人。仅仅因为马略本人不在了，并不意味着他的家族现在就消亡了。继承这个家族领导权的人是马略的儿子，到公元前84年他已经26岁了。但凭借作为这个马略家族首领的身份，他已经是罗马政治中一个非常重要的人物，尽管他还没有担任过任何官职。我们提到过他，上次我们描述过他，他长得很帅，是个花花公子，渴望证明自己是他父亲的儿子。
You know, he wants to prove himself a chip off the old block, I guess. And just on the Marion faction. So in the previous episodes, we talked about how Marius had been a provincial outsider, how he'd appeal to the masses, the popularis, all of this kind of thing. Is that class element and sort of, as a way, regional elements, I suppose, is that still an element of this civil war between Sinner and his people and Sulla and his people? Or is this generated into a kind of wars of the roses struggle between the elites? On one level, on one level, because Marius was an out-of-towner, and he'd always favoured enfranchisement of the Italians who've been in this
你知道，他想证明自己虎父无犬子，我想。关于马略派。在之前的剧集中，我们谈到了马略是如何作为一个外省的局外人，如何吸引大众，即平民派，所有这些。这种阶级因素，以及某种程度上，区域因素，我想，这仍然是秦纳及其支持者与苏拉及其支持者之间内战的一个因素吗？还是这已经演变成了一种精英之间的玫瑰战争式的斗争？在某种层面上，是的，因为马略是个外地人，他一直支持意大利人的公民权，他们经历过这场……
great war, we might come to that in a minute. And so he is backed by the Italians, basically, and they view Sulla as their great enemy. But in general, the fact that a powerful Roman aristocrat or player appeals over the head of the Senate to the people doesn't mean that, you know, they're socialist or that they themselves are necessarily identifying themselves with the masses of the plebeians in the Roman slums any more than the fact that, I don't know, Donald Trump is very popular with people who don't have high incomes mean that Donald Trump himself is, you know, from the masses. Essentially, the Romans, it's less about policy, it's more about vibe.
伟大的战争，我们一会儿可能会谈到。所以他基本上得到了意大利人的支持，他们视苏拉为他们的大敌。但总的来说，一个强大的罗马贵族或政客越过元老院直接向人民呼吁，并不意味着他们是社会主义者，或者他们本身必然将自己与罗马贫民窟的平民大众等同起来，就像唐纳德·特朗普在低收入人群中很受欢迎，并不意味着唐纳德·特朗普本人来自大众一样。本质上，罗马人，这与其说是关于政策，不如说是关于氛围。
It's about whether you are seen to be on the side of the people, whether you like them, I guess, whether you enjoy their pleasures and if you don't, then you are part of the kind of the aristocratic faction, but basically everybody is aristocratic in the upper echelons of Roman society. Okay. And it's important to keep all that in mind. So this is, I think, ultimately, it's not a civil war about principle. It's a civil war about power.
这是关于你是否被视为站在人民一边，你是否喜欢他们，我想，你是否享受他们的快乐，如果你不这样做，那么你就是贵族派系的一部分，但基本上罗马社会上层的所有人都是贵族。好的。记住所有这些是很重要的。所以，我认为这最终不是一场关于原则的内战。这是一场关于权力的内战。
And this is why someone like Sinner, someone like Marius Jr., they are never going to arrive at an accommodation with Sulla. They are complete diehards. And it's not over points of principle. It's over issues of personal ambition and rivalry. Yeah. But they don't underestimate Sulla though, do they? I mean, they know by now what an absolutely implacable and formidable opponent he is. I mean, he's an outlaw. His property has been confiscated and the property of his supporters. He doesn't have a voice in Rome. And yet, on the other hand, you know, he's an extremely practiced and accomplished commander. He has his legions, whose loyalty to him, I'm assuming, because they fought in the East must be. absolutely unwavering at this point. Yeah, because Sulla's, you know, provided them with enormous amounts of loot. Of course. I mean, they, they all absolutely love him. So how are Sinha and the
这就是为什么像秦纳、小马略这样的人，他们永远不会与苏拉达成妥协。他们是彻底的死硬派。这不是原则问题。这是个人野心和竞争的问题。是的。但他们并没有低估苏拉，对吧？我的意思是，他们现在知道他是一个绝对不可调和且强大的对手。我的意思是，他是一个被放逐者。他的财产和他的支持者的财产都被没收了。他在罗马没有发言权。然而，另一方面，你知道，他是一位经验极其丰富且成就卓著的指挥官。他有他的军团，他们的忠诚，我假设，因为他们在东方战斗过，现在一定是绝对坚定不移的。是的，因为苏拉为他们提供了大量的战利品。当然。我的意思是，他们都绝对爱他。那么秦纳和……
Marianne's going to, I mean, what do they have to compete with that? Well, Sinner has legions as a, as a consul. Marius has supporters by virtue of his name. And then, of course, there are the Italians, the people who had been at war with the Romans a decade before, now have largely been pacified, and lots of them are being enfranchised. So essentially, the way that the Romans had solved that war had stopped the Italians from breaking away. There was a kind of two-pronged strategy. So one of them was to give actually what the Italians had always been fighting for, which was access to full Roman citizenship.
马略派要怎么做，我的意思是，他们有什么可以与之竞争的？嗯，秦纳作为执政官拥有军团。马略凭借他的名字拥有支持者。然后，当然还有意大利人，那些十年前与罗马人交战的人，现在大部分已经被安抚，许多人获得了公民权。所以本质上，罗马人解决那场战争的方式阻止了意大利人的分裂。这是一种双管齐下的策略。其中之一是给予意大利人一直为之奋斗的东西，即获得完全的罗马公民权。
And from the beginning of the war, the Senate had been saying to Italian communities that didn't revolt or laid their arms down, look, you can have the citizenship. But also this had been combined with very brutal military suppression of those who were still up in arms. And Sulla's role in these twin strategies had not made him popular with the Italians. So when it came to the enfranchisement of the Italians, Sulla was always dragging his feet. He was felt by the Italians not to be keen on this process. He was clearly not an enthusiast for it. He was agreeing to it reluctantly. And as a field commander in the war, he had been by far the most lethal and brutal of all the generals and therefore the most successful as well.
从战争一开始，元老院就一直在对那些没有反抗或放下武器的意大利社区说，看，你们可以获得公民权。但这同时也伴随着对那些仍然武装反抗的人的极其残酷的军事镇压。苏拉在这两种策略中的角色并没有让他受到意大利人的欢迎。所以当谈到意大利人的公民权时，苏拉总是拖拖拉拉。意大利人觉得他并不热衷于这个过程。他显然不是这个过程的热情支持者。他是在勉强同意。作为战争中的前线指挥官，他是所有将军中迄今为止最致命、最残忍的，因此也是最成功的。
And he particularly targeted a people called the Samnites. Yeah, we talked about them. The guys who are prone to shaving their private parts in public. But they're also, you know, they're very effective fighters. and for this reason Sulla had particularly targeted them, and the Samnites had borne the brunt of Sulla's reprisals. And Samnium, which is this stretch of the Apennines, which rise to the east of the Bay of Naples, south of Rome, this remains largely unpassified. And so here, should the Marians wish to employ them, I think there is a third ready resource of men who are willing to oppose Sulla. So you have Sinner's armies, you have the Marians, and potentially you have the Samnites as well.
他特别针对一个叫萨姆尼特人的民族。是的，我们谈到过他们。那些喜欢在公共场合刮掉私处毛发的家伙。但他们也是非常有效的战士。正因为如此，苏拉特别针对他们，而萨姆尼特人承受了苏拉报复的主要打击。萨姆尼乌姆，也就是那片亚平宁山脉的延伸地带，在那不勒斯湾以东、罗马以南，这片地区在很大程度上仍然没有被安抚。所以在这里，如果马略派希望利用他们，我想有第三种现成的资源，即愿意反对苏拉的人。所以你有秦纳的军队，你有马略派，可能还有萨姆尼特人。
Right. So what is Sinner's plan? What's his strategy? He could wait for Sulla to land in Italy and deal with him then, or he could take the offensive and go after him in Greece. I have to say people going after Roman adversaries in Greece doesn't tend to end well. Anyway, let's see what happens to us. Well, you're right. basically every Roman general who crosses to Greece to fight civil war, it all goes wrong.
对。那么秦纳的计划是什么？他的策略是什么？他可以等苏拉登陆意大利后再对付他，或者他可以主动出击，去希腊追击他。我不得不说，罗马将军去希腊追击对手往往没什么好下场。不管怎样，让我们看看会发生什么。嗯，你是对的。基本上每个跨海到希腊打内战的罗马将军，结果都很糟糕。
And sinners attempt to do this is the first in a long line. So what does he do? He and his fellow consul, they raise their armies, they go down with the Merians, they go to a port called Ancona, which is in Pisinum, this region on the east coast of central Italy. And an initial contingent crosses the Adriatic. All is looking well. And then there's a second fleet crosses with loaded down with men. and this is hit by a storm and the ships are forced back into harbour. And when the storm dies down and Sinner says, okay, we're ready to go.
而秦纳试图这样做是这一长串失败中的第一个。那么他做了什么？他和他的同僚执政官，他们集结军队，带着马略派，前往一个叫安科纳的港口，位于意大利中部东海岸的皮塞努姆地区。第一批部队跨过了亚得里亚海。一切看起来都很顺利。然后第二支舰队载满了人出发了。但这支舰队遇到了风暴，船只被迫返回港口。当风暴平息，秦纳说，好吧，我们准备出发了。
Can you board ships and we'll continue with the crossing? They say they're not going to go. And there's a mass process of desertion. And the mutiny starts to spread throughout the camp. Sinner is furious at this. He's being directly insulted. He's being disobeyed. He is a consul of the Roman people.
你们能登船吗，我们将继续横渡？他们说他们不去了。于是发生了大规模的逃兵潮。哗变开始在整个营地蔓延。秦纳对此感到愤怒。他受到了直接的侮辱。他被违抗了。他是罗马人民的执政官。
and so he summons his men to an assembly to remind them of their duty. The men gather in a great assembly, Sinner starts to march through them to take the Rostrum. But as he's pushing his way through the mass of soldiers and his lictors, his bodyguards, each consul has 12 of these lictors armed with rods, they're kind of beating away through. One of the rods catches a soldier painfully and the soldier hits the lictor in the face. and there is then an absolutely massive pile on. The soldiers start to throw stones at Sinner and his bodyguard. They then draw their swords and they stab Sinner to death.
于是他召集士兵开会，提醒他们履行职责。士兵们聚集在一起，秦纳开始穿过人群走向讲坛。但当他挤过士兵和他的侍从（每位执政官有12名配备棍棒的侍从）时，棍棒在开路。其中一根棍棒痛苦地击中了一名士兵，士兵打了侍从的脸。随后发生了大规模的冲突。士兵们开始向秦纳和他的保镖投掷石块。然后他们拔出剑，将秦纳刺死。
What? So Sinner never even makes it across the Greece. He is dead in this port town of Ancona. Sinner, what an end for him. Oh my God. No one saw that coming. Yeah. Well, it's a massive stroke of luck for Sulla.
什么？所以秦纳甚至没能跨过希腊。他在安科纳这个港口小镇死了。秦纳，真是个悲惨的结局。天哪。没人预料到会这样。是的。嗯，这对苏拉来说真是天大的好运。
Well, he was Felix, wasn't he? He was blessed with the fortune by Venus, I think. Yes. And so he's laughing. He's absolutely laughing once again. He absolutely is. I think for two reasons. And the first is that Sinner himself, despite the fact that he's got himself murdered by his own troops, I mean, he is an effective figure, the most effective of Sulla's opponents.
嗯，他是“幸运者”（Felix），不是吗？我想他是被维纳斯赐予了幸运。是的。所以他现在在笑。他一旦再次笑起来，就绝对是在笑。我想有两个原因。第一个是秦纳本人，尽管他被自己的军队谋杀了，但他确实是一个有效的人物，是苏拉对手中最有效的一个。
And so his loss is a real blow to the cause of those who want to oppose Sulla. Because really the only heavyweight who's left is Marius Jr. but we've said he's only 26. And a 26-year-old could never become a consul. That would be impossible. So essentially, the Merians are left with a massive leadership vacuum. The second reason why this is great news for Sulla is that the contrast between the evident devotion that is felt by Sulla's troops for their general and the death of sinner in a
所以他的损失对那些想要反对苏拉的人来说是一个真正的打击。因为剩下的唯一重量级人物是小马略，但我们说过他只有26岁。一个26岁的人永远不可能成为执政官。那是不可能的。所以本质上，马略派留下了一个巨大的领导真空。第二个原因是这对苏拉来说是个好消息，因为苏拉的军队对他们的将军表现出的明显忠诚，与秦纳在……中死亡的对比，
mutiny is a terrible look for the Marians. And I think that it helps to persuade a number of key waiverers, people who've been sitting on the fence wondering which way to jump, actually that they should probably throw their lot in with Sulla. Right. That he has the look of a winner, even though ostensibly he's outnumbered. And among the ranks of those who at this point start to join with Sulla, there are two of them in particular who, who will become very famous and both of them at this point are very young. And the first of these is the head of a family celebrated, or you might say notorious for its wealth.
哗变，这对马略派来说是一个糟糕的形象。我认为这有助于说服一些关键的摇摆不定的人，那些一直观望不知道该倒向哪边的人，实际上他们应该投靠苏拉。对。他看起来像个赢家，尽管表面上他的人数处于劣势。在此时开始加入苏拉行列的人中，有两个特别出名，而且他们当时都非常年轻。第一个是一个以财富闻名，或者你可能会说臭名昭著的家族的首领。
And this is a man called Marcus Licinius Krasus. Krasus. Great to have him on the show. Great to have him on the show. So his father, Krasis' father, a very reputable family. He'd had a dazzling political career. but he'd also had a very unsanitorial interest in the import-export business. Senators were not supposed to busy themselves with trade, but Krasis' dad had. And as a result, he'd become obscenely rich, and he'd won himself the nickname Divey's or
这个人叫马库斯·李锡尼·克拉苏。克拉苏。很高兴他在节目中。很高兴他在节目中。所以他的父亲，克拉苏的父亲，一个非常显赫的家族。他有过辉煌的政治生涯。但他对进出口贸易也有着非常不符合元老身份的兴趣。元老们本不应该忙于贸易，但克拉苏的父亲却做了。结果，他变得极其富有，并赢得了“富人”或……的绰号。
the rich moneybags. And Krasis' dad had been an opponent of Marius, and so he had been killed in the pogrom of 87 when Marius returned and was psychotic and killing all his enemies. And Crassus is his elder brother as well. And so that had left the young Crassus, who at this point was still only in his early 20s, as the heir to the family name and crucially to its fabulous wealth. But Crassus too, of course, he's being targeted by the Marians too. And so he flees Italy.
钱袋子。克拉苏的父亲曾是马略的对手，所以他在87年的大清洗中被杀，当时马略回来，精神失常，杀死了他所有的敌人。克拉苏的哥哥也被杀了。这使得当时只有20出头的年轻克拉苏成为了家族姓氏的继承人，更重要的是，继承了其惊人的财富。但克拉苏当然也成为了马略派的目标。于是他逃离了意大利。
And he takes ship for Spain, where his father had been a governor. And so he has lots of backers and supporters. And Plutarch, who loves a good story, says that Krasas, to begin with, holds himself up on a cave on a beach. And his dependents bring him both food and Nubal's slave girls to satisfy his various appetites. And so he hangs out in this cave. I mean, whether that's true or not, who knows. But definitely the point comes where Krasn feels that it's safe to reemerge. And he sets to recruiting a legion from among all his father's various clients in Spain.
他乘船前往西班牙，他父亲曾是那里的总督。所以他有很多支持者。普鲁塔克，他喜欢好故事，说克拉苏起初躲在海滩的一个洞穴里。他的随从给他送去食物和努米底亚女奴来满足他的各种欲望。所以他就在那个洞穴里待着。嗯，这是否属实，谁知道呢。但肯定到了克拉苏觉得重新露面是安全的时候了。他开始从他在西班牙的各种父亲的客户中招募一个军团。
And then when he's got the Legion at his back, and the news reaches him that Sinner has been lynched by his own men, he set sail for Italy. And when he lands, he uses his wealth, he uses his connections. He's a very able man as well, very persuasive. And he recruits an even larger force, so swelling the number of men at his back. And later in life, Crassus would make a celebrated comment, a very notorious comment, to the effect that no man could truly be reckoned rich who lacked. the funds to maintain his own army. And I think only someone who had gone through the civil war would ever have thought to say this. So Krasas has quite a substantial military force now at his
然后当他有了军团的支持，并且得知秦纳被他自己的人处以私刑的消息时，他启航前往意大利。当他登陆时，他利用自己的财富，利用自己的人脉。他也是一个非常有能力的人，非常有说服力。他招募了一支更大的部队，增加了他手下的人数。晚年，克拉苏曾发表过一句著名的评论，一句非常臭名昭著的评论，大意是说，如果一个人缺乏维持自己军队的资金，就不能真正被视为富有。我想只有经历过内战的人才会想到说这句话。所以克拉苏现在有了一支相当强大的军事力量在……
back, completely illegal. I mean, you know, it's illegal for citizens to raise their own private armies, but, you know, these are troubled times and Krasn has gone ahead and done it. And so he's looking around and wondering, well, which anti-Marian should I throw my lot in with? And he realizes that Sulla is really the only show in town. And so he crosses his... the Adriatic and he joins with Sulla in Greece and Sulla thinks this is tremendous and they become great pals. Sulla is very, very welcoming to him. Yeah. So that's number one. Who's the second man? The second man, he is even younger than Krasis and he is even more glamorous. He's actually a lot more glamorous. Sulla doesn't meet with him in Greece. He meets with him after he has crossed
背后，完全是非法的。我的意思是，你知道，公民建立自己的私人军队是非法的，但，你知道，这是动荡时期，克拉苏已经这样做了。所以他环顾四周，想知道，我应该投靠哪位反马略派人士？他意识到苏拉确实是城里唯一的选择。于是他跨过亚得里亚海，在希腊加入了苏拉，苏拉认为这太棒了，他们成了好朋友。苏拉非常、非常欢迎他。是的，那是第一个。第二个人是谁？第二个人，他比克拉苏更年轻，而且更迷人。他实际上要迷人得多。苏拉没有在希腊见到他。他是在他跨过……之后见到他的。
from Greece to Italy and specifically to Brundizium in the heel of Italy. And from there Sulla has He's marching up the roads northwards towards Campania, where the Bay of Naples is. And as he's approaching Campania, he's brought news that another private army has been raised on his behalf. And this private army has been raised in Pisinum on the eastern side of Italy, and it is crossing the Apennines to join him. And when Salar has brought this news, he's anxious that these reinforcements might be ambushed, that they might be surprised by the Marians. And so he orders his men to advance quickly so that they can come to the rescue of this private army that is coming to join him. But as the Sulla and his men are pushing their way up the road towards Campania, further messengers come. And they say, brilliant news.
从希腊到意大利，具体来说是意大利脚跟处的布伦迪西姆。从那里，苏拉一直在向北行军，前往那不勒斯湾所在的坎帕尼亚。当他接近坎帕尼亚时，他得到消息说，另一支私人军队已经以他的名义建立起来了。这支私人军队是在意大利东部的皮塞努姆建立的，它正在跨越亚平宁山脉来加入他。当苏拉得到这个消息时，他担心这些增援部队可能会被伏击，可能会被马略派突袭。于是他命令他的部队快速前进，以便他们能去营救这支前来加入他的私人军队。但当苏拉和他的部下沿着通往坎帕尼亚的道路推进时，更多的信使来了。他们说，好消息。
This army is absolutely fine. It's cross the Apennines. And what is more, it has wiped out, not one, not two, but three hostile Marion armies. And it is waiting for Sulla ahead of him on the road. It's drawn up in a splendid array. And standing at the head of this array of men is its young commander, the man who has personally raised it from his estates in Piscesanum. And he cuts a tremendous dash, this young man. He has golden hair swept up in a quiff.
这支军队完全没问题。它已经跨过了亚平宁山脉。而且更重要的是，它消灭了不是一支，不是两支，而是三支敌对的马略派军队。它正在路上的前方等待苏拉。它以壮观的阵势排列着。站在这些士兵阵列最前面的是它年轻的指挥官，那个亲自从他在皮塞努姆的庄园里招募了这支军队的人。这个年轻人真是风度翩翩。他有一头向上梳起的金色头发。
and he is the spitting image of Alexander the Great. Wow. And Dominic, you know who this young man is. I do actually know who it is. He is Nias Pompeius, isn't he? And he is the son of Pompeius Strabo, the bloat with the squint, who had the worst run of luck in history. He got plague.
他简直就是亚历山大大帝的翻版。哇。多米尼克，你知道这个年轻人是谁。我确实知道他是谁。他是格奈乌斯·庞培，对吧？他是那个有斜视的胖子庞培·斯特拉博的儿子，他有着历史上最糟糕的运气。他得了瘟疫。
And then he was in his tent. And it was struck by lightning. So Strabo died. And I guess his affinity passed to his son, Nias Pompeius. Pompey and Pompey as lots of listeners will know he is the great rising star
然后他在帐篷里。它被闪电击中了。所以斯特拉博死了。我想他的亲和力传给了他的儿子，格奈乌斯·庞培。庞培，正如许多听众所知，他是罗马政治中伟大的新星。
of Roman politics at this point burning with ambition ruthless in turn but a showman I mean he wants to basically he's basically cosplaying as Alexander the Greates isn't he and he has this quiff which you can see you can Google his statues or his busts and you can see the quiff
此时此刻，野心勃勃，冷酷无情，但又是个表演者。我的意思是，他基本上是在扮演亚历山大大帝，不是吗？他有这个发型，你可以看看他的雕像或半身像，你可以看到那个发型。
and later on he used to sort of wear his cloak like Alexander and all sorts of stuff like this but at this point Krasus plus Pompey is quite a, I mean, that's quite a catch for Sulla. Yeah. Krasas, I think, is more obviously the kind of person that Sulla had wanted his back. Pompey is more aberrant because he is so madly young.
后来他习惯像亚历山大那样穿斗篷，诸如此类。但在这一点上，克拉苏加上庞培，这对于苏拉来说是一个相当大的收获。是的。克拉苏，我认为更明显是苏拉想要支持的那种人。庞培更反常，因为他太年轻了。
He's only in his early twenties. Yeah. And why has Pompey chosen to throw his lot in with Sulla? Bear in mind that Strabo, his father, had been notorious as a trimmer, weighing up the odds. Pompey goes full in with Sulla. I think partly it's because Pompey had gone sniffing around Sinner's camp when Sina was at Ancona and had seen him lynched. And so I think that that confirms Pompey in the view that Sulla is the guy to follow. But I think more than that, the reason that Pompey backs Sulla with such commitment is that he can see that civil war has changed the rules of the political game. it has presented the younger generation of Roman aristocrats, nobilees, with a really unparalleled opportunity to leapfrog their elders and their betters. Because normally there are kind of massive age restrictions.
他才20出头。是的。为什么庞培选择投靠苏拉？记住，斯特拉博，他的父亲，曾以墙头草著称，权衡利弊。庞培完全倒向了苏拉。我认为部分原因是庞培在秦纳在安科纳时曾去秦纳的营地打探过，并目睹了他被处以私刑。所以我认为这证实了庞培认为苏拉是值得追随的人。但我认为更重要的是，庞培如此坚定地支持苏拉的原因是他能看出内战改变了政治游戏的规则。它为年轻一代的罗马贵族提供了真正前所未有的机会，让他们可以超越长辈和前辈。因为通常有严格的年龄限制。
The young are not supposed to seize power. They're supposed to wait their turn. But for Pompey, you know, he's not going to follow these rules. Krasis isn't going to follow these rules. and someone else who isn't going to follow these rules is a Marion, in fact the ultimate Marion, the young Marius, the son of Gaius Marius, the seven times consul. Let's just have a look at him before we come to Pompeian Crassus. So the young Marius, he's basically now the figurehead for the opposition to Sulla.
年轻人不应该夺取权力。他们应该等待轮到自己。但对于庞培，你知道，他不会遵守这些规则。克拉苏不会遵守这些规则。还有另一个人也不会遵守这些规则，那就是马略派，事实上是终极马略派，年轻的马略，七次执政官盖乌斯·马略的儿子。在我们谈到庞培和克拉苏之前，让我们先看看他。所以年轻的马略，他现在基本上是反对苏拉的领袖。
And so the fact that he is young and he doesn't have any official magistracy is a huge problem for the Merrian cause. Then, when the Temple of Jupiter burns down, so that was being described in the brilliant reading that you did to open this show, it obviously presents an opportunity for Sulla because the capital is where Sinha had sworn his oath, which he'd then broken. And so Sulla's propagandists can say, well, this demonstrates, you know, Jupiter has destroyed the temple because he's angry with Sinner and his followers. Yeah.
所以他年轻且没有任何官方官职的事实对马略派的事业来说是一个巨大的问题。然后，当朱庇特神庙被烧毁时，也就是你在节目开头所做的精彩朗读中所描述的那样，这显然为苏拉提供了一个机会，因为卡比托利欧山是秦纳发誓的地方，后来他违背了誓言。所以苏拉的宣传人员可以说，好吧，这证明了，你知道，朱庇特摧毁了神庙，因为他生秦纳及其追随者的气。是的。
But it does present an opportunity to. to Marius, because inside the temple of Jupiter, this is where the Romans keep their gold. It's their central bank, if you like. It's where all the financial reserves are kept. So Marius, when he sees the temple up in flames, he rushes up to the top of the capital. And he doesn't bother rescuing the cult statue or any of the kind of great sacral objects are stored there. He scoops up the treasure. And he then uses it to pay for his own private legions. and then he uses it to bribe people to vote for him as consul.
但这确实为马略提供了一个机会。在朱庇特神庙内，这是罗马人存放黄金的地方。如果你愿意的话，这是他们的中央银行。这是所有财政储备存放的地方。所以马略当他看到神庙起火时，他冲向卡比托利欧山顶。他没有费心去抢救崇拜雕像或储存在那里的任何伟大的神圣物品。他卷走了财宝。然后他用它来支付他自己的私人军团。然后他用它来贿赂人们投票选他为执政官。
And so in the year 82, he's going to start a term as consul at the age of 26. And this is just unprecedented and by the standards of Roman convention, completely obscene. And even Sulla is shocked. And he understandably regards Marius Jr. as his deadliest foe. and he kind of made this rueful comment that the older he became, so the younger his foes became. But of course, the same is true of his allies, because Pompey is even younger than the young Marius. And just to emphasize how shocking this is to mainstream Roman opinion, the Romans assume that the passions of young men are violent and dangerous. And this is why it's so important the Romans think that these passions are bitted and bridled, that they are kept under firm control.
所以在82年，他将以26岁的年龄开始担任执政官。这在罗马传统标准下是前所未有的，完全是荒谬的。甚至苏拉也感到震惊。他理所当然地将小马略视为他最致命的敌人。他发表了这种懊悔的评论，说他年纪越大，他的敌人就越年轻。但当然，他的盟友也是如此，因为庞培比年轻的马略还要年轻。为了强调这对主流罗马舆论来说是多么令人震惊，罗马人认为年轻人的激情是暴力和危险的。这就是为什么罗马人认为这些激情必须被束缚和驾驭，必须保持在严格控制之下是如此重要。
But we've said how Sulla, he's a conservative, but he is also a revolutionary. And if he has a sniff of an opportunity, he will take it. And so rather than slap Pompey down for having raised this private army at a very tender age, he thinks Pompey is great. and he gives Pompey free reign, not despite, but because Pompey has the savagery of youth. And Sulla wants to use this savagery to his own ends in the war. And the strategy proves brilliantly successful because by the autumn of 82, so that's a year and a half after Sulla had returned from Greece, the Merion cause is pretty much on the point of collapse.
但我们说过苏拉，他是一位保守派，但他也是一位革命者。如果他嗅到机会，他就会抓住它。所以他没有因为庞培在非常年轻的时候就建立这支私人军队而惩罚他，他认为庞培很棒。他给了庞培自由，不是尽管，而是因为庞培拥有年轻人的野蛮。苏拉想在战争中利用这种野蛮来达到自己的目的。这个策略被证明是非常成功的，因为到了82年秋天，也就是苏拉从希腊回来一年半后，马略派的事业几乎处于崩溃的边缘。
So Pompey, he's up in the north. Sulla has sent him there to clean up all the northern cities at Truaria and so on, what's now Tuscany. And Pompey does this to such effect that all the Merrian forces there, they take ship and withdraw and go to Sicily to try and carry on the fight there. Marius is defeated by Sulla himself in Campania. He withdraws to a town called Preneste, which is 25 miles east of Rome, holds himself up there. And this means that of all Sulla's enemies, the only army that remains in the field in Italy is the army of the Samnites. Oh, yeah. Nice armour, but they're very smooth people. Yes, exactly so. And they hate Sulla with a vengeance. And in a sense, they are perhaps, I mean, even more than young Marius, they are his bitterest and most implacable foes.
所以庞培，他在北方。苏拉派他去那里清理伊特鲁里亚等地的所有北方城市，也就是现在的托斯卡纳。庞培的效果非常好，以至于那里的所有马略派军队都乘船撤退到西西里岛，试图在那里继续战斗。马略在坎帕尼亚被苏拉本人击败。他撤退到罗马以东25英里的普雷内斯特镇，躲在那里。这意味着在苏拉所有的敌人中，意大利境内唯一剩下的军队是萨姆尼特人的军队。哦，是的。盔甲不错，但他们是非常圆滑的人。是的，正是如此。他们对苏拉怀有深仇大恨。在某种意义上，他们也许，甚至比年轻的马略更让他痛苦和不可调和。
Right. They want to relieve the young Marius in Prineste up towards Rome. They evade Sulla and they start marching up towards Prineste and Sulla follows them and the two armies are kind of shadow boxing as they advanced up the road towards Rome and then towards Prioneste. But as the Samnites are drawing close to Prineste and they see that Sulla is on their flank, they suddenly think, God, Rome is completely empty. There's no one guarding it. And the Samnites, of course, have been in a war against Rome. They hate Sulla, but they hate Rome as well. And they think, we could go and capture Rome and put it to the torch.
对。他们想在普雷内斯特解救年轻的马略，向罗马进军。他们避开了苏拉，开始向普雷内斯特进军，苏拉跟随他们，两支军队在沿着通往罗马然后通往普雷内斯特的路上推进时，就像在进行影子拳击。但当萨姆尼特人接近普雷内斯特，看到苏拉在他们的侧翼时，他们突然想，天哪，罗马完全是空的。没有人守卫它。萨姆尼特人，当然，一直在与罗马交战。他们恨苏拉，但也恨罗马。他们想，我们可以去占领罗马并把它烧毁。
What an opportunity. And so they suddenly double back. They swing round. They march towards Rome. And Sulla is taken completely by surprise by this manoeuvre. I hadn't thought that they would do this. And he pursues them at frantic, you know, exhausting speed. and he's chasing them desperately because he knows from his scouts that the Samnites are drawing ever closer to Rome.
真是个好机会。于是他们突然折返。他们转过身。他们向罗马进军。苏拉被这个动作完全打了个措手不及。我没想到他们会这样做。他以疯狂的、令人精疲力竭的速度追赶他们。他拼命追赶，因为他从侦察兵那里知道萨姆尼特人正越来越接近罗马。
And as the sun starts to set, the Samnites are in front of the walls of Rome. And their commander gazes out at the cityscape. And he tells them, prepare to annihilate this monstrous den of evil-doers. And he says, do you think that these wolves who have prayed so terribly, on the freedoms of Italy will ever vanish until the forest that shelters them has been destroyed. And the Samnites, great cheer, let's go and do it, let's wipe Rome out. And they advance on the Colline Gate, this gate in the north. And as they approach it, they can hear the screams of women in the city who think that,
当太阳开始落山时，萨姆尼特人就在罗马城墙前。他们的指挥官凝视着城市景观。他告诉他们，准备消灭这个邪恶之徒的怪物巢穴。他说，你们认为这些在意大利自由上掠夺得如此可怕的狼，在庇护它们的森林被摧毁之前会消失吗？萨姆尼特人欢呼雀跃，让我们去干吧，让我们消灭罗马。他们向科林门，这个北方的门推进。当他们接近它时，他们能听到城里妇女的尖叫声，她们认为……
you know, they're about to be raped and slave killed. However, just as they are approaching the Colline Gate, Sulla's cavalry, which is in advance of the main body of Sulla's army, hits them in the back. hits them in their rear. And by late evening, Sulla has arrived with his exhausted army and against the advice of his lieutenants, he thinks, I'm going to throw them into the battle. I'm not going to give them any chance to recapture their breath. And all evening and long into the night, the battle rages and it ebbs and flows and Krasas is with Sulla and he's commanding the left wing and he shatters the Sambite wing. But Sulla's wing, where he is, that's under enormous pressure.
你知道，她们即将被强奸、奴役和杀害。然而，就在他们接近科林门时，苏拉的骑兵，也就是苏拉军队主力的先头部队，从背后袭击了他们。袭击了他们的后方。到了深夜，苏拉带着他精疲力竭的军队赶到了，不顾副官的建议，他想，我要把他们投入战斗。我不会给他们任何喘息的机会。整个晚上直到深夜，战斗都在激烈进行，起起伏伏，克拉苏和苏拉在一起，他指挥左翼，他粉碎了萨姆尼特人的侧翼。但苏拉所在的侧翼，压力巨大。
And it's on the verge of being broken when Sulla offers up a prayer to Venus, you know, his great patron, you know, and he's not Felix for nothing. Venus hears his prayer. He rallies his men. They fight on. And by dawn as the sun is rising in the east over Rome, the victory is his. And this turns into a bloodbath. And victory, not just in the battle, but effectively in the war. against the Italian allies and the war against the Marians, the victory at the Colline Gate ends both those wars. And it leaves Sulla as the master of Rome. Wow. So Sulla now wields power. Unprecedented really, certainly for generations. He is the master of Rome, but what will he do with it? Will he govern benevolently and wisely or will more blood flow? We will find out after the break. This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps, many of them started as hard questions that people didn't want asked.
当苏拉向维纳斯，你知道，他伟大的守护神祈祷时，它几乎要崩溃了，你知道，他不是白白被称为“幸运者”的。维纳斯听到了他的祈祷。他召集了他的部下。他们继续战斗。到了黎明，当太阳在罗马东方的地平线上升起时，胜利属于他了。这变成了一场大屠杀。胜利，不仅是在战斗中，而且实际上是在战争中。对意大利盟友的战争和对马略派的战争，科林门的胜利结束了这两场战争。它使苏拉成为了罗马的主人。哇。所以苏拉现在掌握了权力。确实是前所未有的，至少几代人以来是这样。他是罗马的主人，但他会用它做什么？他会仁慈而明智地统治，还是会有更多的血流成河？休息后我们将揭晓。本集由Anthropic支持，这是Claude背后的团队。现在，历史上最大的飞跃，其中许多始于人们不想问的难题。
Yeah, there's a classic example of that, Tom, at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus, great pioneering voyage of discovery, and it is, of course, the Americas. So, you know, Anthropic knows the importance of questions, and it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution really goes well for ordinary people? Anthropic asked 100,000 people, and what came back wasn't just fear.
是的，汤姆，在15世纪末有一个经典的例子。那个难题特别在于，大西洋以西有什么？正如你所知，找到那个问题答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布，伟大的发现之旅，当然，那就是美洲。所以，你知道，Anthropic知道问题的重要性，这就是为什么Anthropic建立在一个最重要的难题之上。我们如何确保人工智能革命真正为普通人带来好处？Anthropic询问了10万人，得到的不仅仅是恐惧。
There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? Can kids have a better future? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clod.a.ai slash rest is history. And keep thinking. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers, The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK.
这里也有希望。人们想知道，癌症会被治愈吗？孩子们能有更好的未来吗？事实证明，在困难的问题中蕴含着希望。请在 clod.a.ai slash rest is history 提出你的问题。并保持思考。嘿，这是来自《Gollhangers, The Rest is Science》的迈克尔和汉娜。本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。
Think of some things that glow. Okay, fireflies, glow sticks, the northern lights. They're very cool. But what if we could replicate that glow inside our bodies and what if doing so could help us save lives? Because Cancer Research UK scientists, they're investigating whether a special fluorescent dye that sticks to prostate cancer cells could tackle an ongoing challenge in the operating room, removing every single trace of cancer.
想想一些会发光的东西。好吧，萤火虫、荧光棒、北极光。它们非常酷。但如果我们能在体内复制这种光，如果这样做能帮助我们拯救生命呢？因为英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在研究一种能粘附在前列腺癌细胞上的特殊荧光染料，是否能解决手术室中一个持续存在的挑战，即清除癌症的每一丝痕迹。
Because when cancer cells are glowing and easy to spot, surgeons can precisely remove them, leaving healthy cells untouched, meaning there's less chance of the cancer returning and fewer nasty side effects. Cancer Research UK's vision is a world where everybody lives long. longer, better lives free from the fear of cancer, with breakthroughs like this leading to kinder, more effective treatments. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit canterresearchuk.org slash rest is science. Welcome back to The Rest is history. The date is the 2nd of November, 82 BC. So this is the day
因为当癌细胞发光且容易被发现时，外科医生可以精确地切除它们，而不触及健康细胞，这意味着癌症复发的几率更小，且副作用更少。英国癌症研究中心的愿景是一个每个人都能活得更长、更好，且没有癌症恐惧的世界，像这样的突破性进展将带来更温和、更有效的治疗方法。欲了解更多关于英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及如何支持他们的信息，请访问 canterresearchuk.org slash rest is science。欢迎回到《The Rest is history》。日期是公元前82年11月2日。所以这是
after Sulla's tremendous victory against the Samnites in the Battle of the Colline Gate. Outside the gate, there are piles of rotting bodies. Sulla's men have rounded up 6,000 prisoners, and Sulla, rather than allow them onto the sacred soil of Rome, has led them to the campus, Marcius, the flat expanse beyond the city walls. And Tom, this is where the Romans would assemble to go to war, isn't it, and where they would gather to vote for their magistrates?
苏拉在科林门战役中大胜萨姆尼特人之后的一天。门外堆满了腐烂的尸体。苏拉的手下围捕了6000名俘虏，苏拉没有让他们进入罗马的神圣土地，而是把他们带到了马尔斯广场，即城墙外那片平坦的空地。汤姆，这就是罗马人集结去打仗的地方，也是他们聚集投票选举地方官的地方，对吧？
Yeah. Give us some sense of the scene on the field of Mars as Sulla arrives with his prisoners. Yes, as you said, it's the kind of flat open play. and so there aren't many public amenities on the campus. But of the buildings that do stand there, the largest is this very grand formal building called the Villa, so the public villa. And it consists of a square, two-storied reception hall, and it's adorned with paintings and
是的。给我们描述一下苏拉带着俘虏到达马尔斯广场时的场景。是的，正如你所说，那是一片平坦的开阔地，所以广场上没有多少公共设施。但在那里矗立的建筑中，最大的是一座非常宏伟的正式建筑，叫做 Villa，即公共别墅。它由一个方形的两层接待大厅组成，装饰着绘画和
sculptures, and its ground floor is decorated with arches, and beyond these arches, their stretches are walled enclosure. And this is where magistrates called the census who every five years would hold a census so that the Romans knew where they stood in relation to all their fellow citizens. This is where they were based. This is where the census would be done. And it's also where foreign ambassadors would be greeted. And it's where generals who were granted triumphs would spend the night before they enter the Rome with their troops. So it's a kind of, I suppose it's a symbol really of the functioning of the Roman Republic, the entire Roman political system.
雕塑，其底层装饰着拱门，在这些拱门之外，延伸着一个围墙围起来的区域。这就是被称为“监察官”的地方官每五年举行一次人口普查的地方，这样罗马人就能知道他们在所有公民中的地位。这就是他们办公的地方。这就是进行人口普查的地方。这也是迎接外国大使的地方。也是被授予凯旋式的将军们在带着军队进入罗马前过夜的地方。所以，我想这确实是罗马共和国运作、整个罗马政治体系的一个象征。
And it is here in that walled enclosure of the villa publica that the 6,000 Samnite prisoners are penned up very, very tightly. There's really not very much space for them. Meanwhile, Sulla has entered Rome, where he hasn't been for many years. Of course, he's been absent on campaign in Greece and Asia. And he summons the Senate to a meeting, not in the Senate House, but in the temple of a goddess called Bologna, who is, as her name suggests, the goddess of war. Sulla has chosen it with his kind of customary shrewdness and care. So it stands within listening distance of the Villa Publica. People in it will be able to hear what's going on in the Villa Publica, but it's also
正是在公共别墅的那个围墙区域里，6000名萨姆尼特俘虏被非常非常紧密地关押着。他们确实没有多少空间。与此同时，苏拉进入了罗马，他已经很多年没来过这里了。当然，他一直远在希腊和亚洲作战。他召集元老院开会，不是在元老院大厦，而是在一位名叫贝洛娜的女神的神庙里，正如她的名字所暗示的那样，她是战争女神。苏拉以他那种惯有的精明和谨慎选择了这里。它距离公共别墅在听力范围内。里面的人将能够听到公共别墅里发生的事情，但它也
within sight of the capital where the charred remains of the Great Temple of Jupiter can be seen as well. And this is important for Sulla's purposes, because back in the spring of 83, when he and his army had landed at Brondissium from Greece, Bologna, the goddess, had put one of Sulla's slaves into a prophetic trance. And speaking through the slave, the goddess had foretold the destruction of Jupiter's temple, which hadn't yet happened at that point, unless the Marians surrendered and submitted to Sulla's benign rule. Wow. And of course, the Marians had not surrendered, and so the temple had duly burnt to the ground. And Sulla remained.
在卡皮托利诺山的视线范围内，在那里也可以看到朱庇特大神庙烧焦的遗迹。这对苏拉的目的很重要，因为早在公元前83年春天，当他和他的军队从希腊在布隆迪西乌姆登陆时，女神贝洛娜曾让苏拉的一名奴隶进入了预言性的恍惚状态。通过这名奴隶，女神预言了朱庇特神庙的毁灭，当时这件事还没有发生，除非马略派投降并屈服于苏拉的仁慈统治。哇。当然，马略派没有投降，所以神庙果然被烧成了平地。而苏拉仍然
reminds the Senate of this and he says to them, well, that's all the evidence you need. I have won. I have defeated the Merians. I stand before you as the self-evident favorite of the gods appointed by them to serve you and Rome as your savior. Now, what does this mean in practice? Well, it soon becomes clear. Because as Sal is talking to the Senate and he's moved on to describing his great victories over Mithridates, senators start to hear kind of muffled bangings and bumpings coming from the fillip publica and then screams and then more screams and then a lot of screams. And Sulla continues, seemingly oblivious to all the noise that is drifting across the campus and then he pauses and he says, I see that you've noticed that something is going on in the Villa Publica. please, please don't be distracted by it. And then to quote, this is what he's recorded as saying,
提醒元老院这一点，他对他们说，好吧，这就是你们所需要的所有证据。我赢了。我击败了马略派。我作为众神显而易见的宠儿站在你们面前，被他们任命为你们和罗马的救世主。现在，这在实践中意味着什么呢？好吧，很快就清楚了。因为当苏拉正在对元老院讲话，并转而描述他战胜米特拉达梯的伟大胜利时，元老们开始听到从公共别墅传来那种沉闷的撞击声和碰撞声，然后是尖叫声，然后是更多的尖叫声，然后是大量的尖叫声。苏拉继续说着，似乎对飘过广场的所有噪音毫无察觉，然后他停顿了一下，说，我看到你们注意到公共别墅里正在发生一些事情。请，请不要被它分心。然后引用他的话，这是他被记录下来的话，
some criminals are receiving their punishment. There is no need to worry. It is all being done on my orders. And of course, what is happening is that those 6,000 Sammite prisoners are being systematically massacred. And when the killing is done, the corpses of the prisoners are dragged across the campus and tossed into the tiber. And for days afterwards, they clogged up the burghed up.
一些罪犯正在接受他们的惩罚。无需担心。这一切都是按照我的命令进行的。当然，正在发生的事情是那6000名萨姆尼特俘虏正在被系统地屠杀。当杀戮完成后，俘虏的尸体被拖过广场，扔进台伯河。在接下来的几天里，它们堵塞了
bridges and the banks and the memory of it was something very terrible and there was a poet years later who wrote that the corpses stayed in the river until at last its currents cut a swath of blood through the azure open sea so a very vivid chilling image yeah eliminating the samnites is one thing but sullers bloodthirsty ambitions to not end there do they because all this time that he has been away, he has been brooding and he knows exactly what he wants to do and he thinks there are too many people in Rome and a lot of them have got to go. Yeah, there are a lot of people in Rome whom he holds responsible for insulting him, condemning him as a public enemy, expelling his family and his friends from Italy. He has a lot of hatred stored up and
桥梁和河岸，这段记忆非常可怕，多年后有一位诗人写道，尸体留在河里，直到最后它的水流在蔚蓝的开阔海面上划出了一道血迹，这是一个非常生动、令人不寒而栗的画面。是的，消灭萨姆尼特人是一回事，但苏拉嗜血的野心并没有就此结束，不是吗？因为他离开的这段时间里，他一直在沉思，他确切地知道他想做什么，他认为罗马的人太多了，其中很多人必须走。是的，罗马有很多人他认为应该为侮辱他、谴责他为公敌、将他的家人和朋友驱逐出意大利负责。他积攒了大量的仇恨，并且
Sulla is a tremendous hater. So what he does is to send death squads fanning out across Rome, even as the Samnite prisoners are being slaughtered in the Villa Publica. And their targets, of course, are supporters of the Merion regime and all its most prominent members. And the scale of the killing is much greater than the killing that Rome had seen back in the days of the Gracki. It's much greater than the scale of the killing that Marius had.
苏拉是一个极其痛恨他人的人。所以他所做的是派遣敢死队散布在罗马各地，即使萨姆尼特俘虏正在公共别墅被屠杀。当然，他们的目标是马略政权的支持者及其所有最杰出的成员。杀戮的规模远比罗马在格拉古兄弟时代所见到的杀戮要大得多。这远比马略所
launched. It seems something utterly terrifying even to Sulla's own supporters. And one of them dares to ask Sulla, you know, when are the killings going to end? You know, when are you going to rein these death squads in? And then he, you know, he's worried that Sulla might be offended. And so he stammers. And he says, well, you know, at least let us have a list of all those that you are planning to punish. And Sulla, who is, he's a very sardonic man. And he's a very sardonic man says, fine. And so he draws up a list and he has it posted in the forum. And over the days and weeks that follow, more lists follow. And hundreds and perhaps thousands of names appear on these lists. So to clarify, these are kill lists prepared by the Master of Rome against Rome's own
发起的杀戮规模要大。即使对苏拉自己的支持者来说，这似乎也极其可怕。其中一个人敢于问苏拉，你知道，杀戮什么时候才会结束？你知道，你什么时候会收回这些敢死队？然后他，你知道，他担心苏拉可能会被冒犯。所以他结结巴巴地说。他说，好吧，你知道，至少让我们有一份你计划惩罚的所有人的名单。而苏拉，他是一个非常讽刺的人。他是一个非常讽刺的人，说，好吧。于是他起草了一份名单，并把它贴在广场上。在接下来的几天和几周里，更多的名单随之而来。成百上千甚至数千个名字出现在这些名单上。所以澄清一下，这些是罗马的主人针对罗马自己
people. Yes. And if your name appears on a prescription list, this is very bad news. Because all your properties are forfeit. Your sons and your grandsons are barred from standing for office. And if anyone helps you, tries to protect you, tries to hide you, then they likewise are condemned to death. So there's nothing good about this at all. Not only are you put to death, but essentially there is an attempt by Sulla to expedite your dynasty as well. And in time, it's not only Mary and supporters who start to appear on these prescription lists. So unsurprisingly, anyone who has a name for wealth and isn't a particular friend of Sulla's, you know, you might have a swimming pool or a pleasure garden or a fancy villa on the Bay of Naples.
人民准备的杀戮名单。是的。如果你的名字出现在处决名单上，这是一个非常坏的消息。因为你所有的财产都被没收。你的儿子和孙子被禁止担任公职。如果有人帮助你，试图保护你，试图隐藏你，那么他们同样会被判处死刑。所以这根本没有什么好事。你不仅被处死，而且苏拉基本上也试图消灭你的王朝。久而久之，开始出现在这些处决名单上的不仅仅是马略的支持者。所以不出所料，任何有财富名声且不是苏拉特别朋友的人，你知道，你可能在那不勒斯湾有一个游泳池、一个休闲花园或一座豪华别墅。
This becomes reason for people to secrete names onto the prescription lists. And essentially, if you are rich, you are probably going to. to be visited by a bounty hunter. And the person who is very, very shameless at smuggling the names of rich people onto the prescription lists is Krasas, divas, the money bags. There's nothing he enjoys more than ill-gained loot. And finally, he goes way too far and he is so blatant with what he's doing that Sulla decides to rein him in and say enough is enough, gives him a very public upbraiding.
这成为人们将名字秘密放入处决名单的原因。本质上，如果你很富有，你很可能会被赏金猎人拜访。而那个非常、非常无耻地将富人的名字塞进处决名单的人是克拉苏，迪瓦斯，钱袋子。没有什么比不义之财更让他享受的了。最后，他做得太过分了，他所做的事情如此明目张胆，以至于苏拉决定约束他，说适可而止，并对他进行了非常公开的训斥。
And I think on Sulla's part, that is quite shrewd politics because it enables Sulla himself to pose not as someone who is kind of selfish and grasping. He's not doing it supposedly for personal gain. But because he is the selfless defender of Rome and if he is having to wash Rome in the blood of those who have done wrong and have offended the gods, then so be it. He knows his duty as an upstanding citizen. So this is something extraordinary that Seller is doing, publishing these lists, killing all these people, sending out his death squads. He doesn't need to do it because he's worn.
我认为就苏拉而言，那是相当精明的政治，因为它使苏拉自己能够表现得不像是一个自私和贪婪的人。他这样做据称不是为了个人利益。而是因为他是罗马无私的捍卫者，如果他不得不让罗马沐浴在那些做错事并冒犯了神灵的人的鲜血中，那就这样吧。他知道他作为一个正直公民的职责。所以这是苏拉正在做的非同寻常的事情，发布这些名单，杀死所有这些人，派出他的敢死队。他不需要这样做，因为他已经赢了。
Why does he do it then? Well, he's a very vengeful man, as Marius was. He wants his vengeance. He's been brooding on his vengeance for years. And I think the longer he broods, the larger his appetite for vengeance has grown. And very grisly stories are told about Sulla's behaviour during. the prescriptions, again, they may be exaggerated, but the fact that they're told, I think, you know, it's always telling. So how do you know that someone has been killed? Well, the bounty
那他为什么要这样做呢？好吧，他是一个非常记仇的人，就像马略一样。他想要他的复仇。他多年来一直在沉思他的复仇。而且我认为他沉思的时间越长，他对复仇的胃口就越大。关于苏拉在处决期间的行为，人们讲述了一些非常可怕的故事，同样，它们可能被夸大了，但它们被讲述的事实，我认为，你知道，总是说明问题的。那么你怎么知道某人已经被杀死了呢？好吧，赏金
hunters have to decapitate the corpse of anyone that they have hunted down and bring the head to Sulla and his agents. And these agents would then inspect the head, and if they're satisfied, then they will release the promised fee. And if the head, and if the head, the head, heads belong to someone whom these agents know Sulla particularly hated, they will alert their master and it is claimed that Sulla would keep some of the heads, you know, particular choice specimens. And you can imagine him kind of going in for a gloat over his enemies. I said I was very much on Sulla's team in the last episode and everything I hear about and he sounds a brilliant person. So vengeance is his. I think also, of course,
猎人必须将他们追捕的任何人的尸体斩首，并将头颅带给苏拉和他的代理人。这些代理人随后会检查头颅，如果他们满意，那么他们就会发放承诺的费用。如果头颅，如果头颅，头颅属于这些代理人知道苏拉特别痛恨的人，他们会提醒他们的主人，据称苏拉会保留一些头颅，你知道，特别精选的样本。你可以想象他那种对敌人幸灾乐祸的样子。我在上一集中非常支持苏拉，我听到的一切关于他的事情，他听起来是一个才华横溢的人。所以复仇是他的。我认为当然，
it enables him to impoverish his enemies and to enrich his friends. You know, money is power. And Sulla himself would, you know, he would buy lots of these kind of properties at knock down prices and then he would sell them on to his own family and friends. So Marius's villa, for instance, the one that was built to look like a legionary camp on the Bay of Naples. He sells that basically for about, you know, four quid to his own daughter. So Maris's villa passes into the family of Sulla.
这也使他能够让他的敌人贫困化，并让他的朋友致富。你知道，金钱就是权力。苏拉自己会，你知道，他会以低廉的价格购买很多这类房产，然后把它们转卖给自己的家人和朋友。所以马略的别墅，例如，那座建得像那不勒斯湾军团营地的别墅。他基本上以大约，你知道，四英镑的价格卖给了他自己的女儿。所以马略的别墅落入了苏拉的家族手中。
It's exactly the kind of thing that Sulla loves. And so his entire regime is entrenched by this process. So Sala's Roman historian writing a few decades later, I mean, he identifies what Sulla is doing very precisely. And he says that not until Sulla had glutted all his followers of wealth, did the slaughter at last come to an end. And it's that emphasis on his followers, I think, that is key. Sulla wants to make sure that those who follow him have a material.
这正是苏拉喜欢的那种事情。所以他的整个政权都是通过这个过程巩固的。所以萨拉的罗马历史学家在几十年后写道，我的意思是，他非常精确地指出了苏拉正在做的事情。他说，直到苏拉让所有的追随者都吃饱了财富，屠杀才最终结束。我认为对他的追随者的强调是关键。苏拉想确保那些追随他的人有一个物质上的
real basis for doing so as well as personal loyalty to him. Smart politics, I suppose. Yeah. I mean, corrupt politics, but smart. Brutal politics, but smart. Yeah. And what about now, not all the Marians, of course, are in Rome. There are some outside Rome, most obviously, Marius Jr.
现实基础，而不仅仅是对他的个人忠诚。我想这是聪明的政治。是的。我的意思是，腐败的政治，但很聪明。残酷的政治，但很聪明。是的。那么现在，当然，并非所有的马略派都在罗马。罗马城外还有一些人，最明显的是小马略。
Where's he? What's he up to? He's still hold up in Praneste. So that's where Sulla and the Samnites were kind of marching towards before the Battle of the Collin Gate. Sulla pretty much the moment that he, you know, he's addressed to Senate. He's launched the prescriptions. He then gets his army back and he marches back on Perneste to finish the young Marius of. But before he can reach there, news is brought to him that Marius has committed
他在哪里？他在干什么？他仍然躲在普雷内斯泰。所以这就是苏拉和萨姆尼特人在科林门战役前行军前往的地方。苏拉几乎在他，你知道，他向元老院发表讲话的那一刻。他发起了处决。然后他召回了他的军队，并向普雷内斯泰进军，以解决年轻的马略。但在他到达那里之前，有人带给他消息说马略已经自杀了
suicide. He knows the game is up and Sulla is delighted because with the suicide of Marius Jr., the line of Gaius Marius, his great rival, his former commander, the man he's measured himself against all his life, it's extinct. The Merion line is dead and Sulla is so delighted by this that this This adjective he has consistently applied to himself, Felix, the lucky one. He adopts it as a formal name. And we've said the more names you have in Rome, generally the better you've done, the kind of the grander you are. So Sulla now has four names. And one of these is a celebration of the fact that he has made the Marian line extinct. Do you know, there are so many elements of Sulla's character that I think anticipate
他知道大势已去，苏拉很高兴，因为随着小马略的自杀，盖乌斯·马略的血脉，他伟大的对手，他曾经的指挥官，他一生都在与之较量的人，已经绝迹了。马略派的血脉断绝了，苏拉对此感到非常高兴，以至于这个他一直用来称呼自己的形容词，Felix，幸运者。他将其作为正式名称。我们说过，在罗马，你的名字越多，通常说明你做得越好，你越显赫。所以苏拉现在有四个名字。其中一个是为了庆祝他已经让马略派的血脉绝迹。你知道，我认为苏拉性格中有许多元素预示着
Octavian, Augustus, later on, not least the changing his name in the in the wake of victory. Well, and also his willingness, I mean, Octavian, when he becomes a consul for the first time, I think he's only 18, the guy who provides the precedent for that is Pompey, who isn't given a consulship at this point by Sulla, but is given a very, very important military command, namely to go to Sicily and Africa and to clean up the Merians who have taken refuge there. Pompey has a lovely time.
后来的屋大维，奥古斯都，尤其是他在胜利后改名。嗯，还有他的意愿，我的意思是，屋大维，当他第一次成为执政官时，我想他只有18岁，为之提供先例的人是庞培，他在这一点上没有被苏拉授予执政官职位，但被赋予了一个非常、非常重要的军事指挥权，即前往西西里和非洲，清理在那里避难的马略派。庞培玩得很开心。
He leads his legions with, I don't know, the kind of insouciance of a small boy given a new toy. He has such fun. So he goes to Sicily first. He cleans up there and he captures the Marion commander and rather than put him on trial, he has him executed without any due legal process. And this causes a lot of outrage back in Rome. And Pompey's enemies give him this nickname, Adulescentulus Carnifex, the teenage butcher. which will cling to him for quite a long time, even once he's into his middle age. But Pompey doesn't care about this.
他带领他的军团，我不知道，带着一种小男孩得到新玩具般的漫不经心。他玩得太开心了。所以他先去了西西里。他在那里进行了清理，并俘虏了马略派的指挥官，他没有对他进行审判，而是未经任何正当法律程序就将他处决了。这在罗马引起了很大的愤怒。庞培的敌人给了他这个绰号，Adulescentulus Carnifex，少年屠夫。这将在很长一段时间内伴随着他，即使在他步入中年之后。但庞培并不在乎这一点。
He cares. He's a winner. And so from Sicily, he crosses to Africa, where again, he wipes the floor with Sulla's enemies. And at the end of these campaigns, the legions who followed him are really, really impressed. They think Pompey is, you know, he's dashing, he's a brilliant commander. He really does seem to have a smack of Alex. And so they call him Magnus the great.
他在乎。他是一个赢家。所以从西西里，他跨海到了非洲，在那里他又一次横扫了苏拉的敌人。在这些战役结束时，追随他的军团真的、真的很佩服他。他们认为庞培是，你知道，他很潇洒，是一位出色的指挥官。他看起来确实有亚历山大的风采。所以他们称他为 Magnus，伟大的。
Pompey the great. At this point, Pompey is still only 25. Wow. But he loves it. He loves it. Because, of course, Alexander had been young. And so Pompey is sharing in the glamour, or, you know, of a kind of a youthful kind of Macedonian king.
庞培大帝。此时，庞培才25岁。哇。但他喜欢它。他喜欢它。因为，当然，亚历山大曾经很年轻。所以庞培正在分享那种魅力，或者，你知道，一种年轻的马其顿国王的魅力。
So when Pompey returns to Italy, you know, it's kind of gone to his head. He doesn't want to behave like a conventional Roman commander. who, once he's returned to Italy, has to disband his troops. Pompey says, he sends a message to Sulla and says, I'm not disbanding my legions. I want a triumph. And just to reiterate, he is only 25. This is completely without precedent.
所以当庞培回到意大利时，你知道，这有点冲昏了他的头脑。他不想表现得像一个传统的罗马指挥官。一旦回到意大利，就必须解散他的军队。庞培说，他给苏拉发了一条信息说，我不会解散我的军团。我想要一场凯旋式。再重申一遍，他才25岁。这完全没有先例。
And Sulla says, no way. You know, you'd have a triumph. That offends against every custom. You know, this is the guy who's just slaughtered large numbers of people. But whatever, he's a conservative. Pompey doesn't back down. And he says to Sulla, more people worship the rising sun than the setting sun.
苏拉说，没门。你知道，你会举行凯旋式。这违背了所有的习俗。你知道，这家伙刚刚屠杀了大量的人。但无论如何，他是一个保守派。庞培没有退缩。他对苏拉说，崇拜初升太阳的人比崇拜落日的人多。
It's a tremendous comment. I mean, does he say this to Sulla? He does say it. Does Sulla not like immediately have put him on one of his lists or something? No, he doesn't. Not only does he grant the triumph, but he officially confirms his protege in the title that his soldiers have given him, the title of Magnus.
这是一个了不起的评论。我的意思是，他真的对苏拉说了这句话吗？他确实说了。苏拉难道没有立即把他列入他的名单或类似的东西吗？不，他没有。他不仅批准了凯旋式，而且正式确认了他的门徒拥有士兵们给他的头衔，即 Magnus 的头衔。
So from this point on, it's Pompeius Magnus. So he's got another name. Interesting that Sulla would do that when Sulla is somebody who is so attuned to the jealousies and resentments of Roman politics that he would give way to Pompey. Now, people listen to this may say, well, Sulla does this because he recognises that Pompey is a threat to him and he feels he has no choice.
所以从这一点开始，他就是庞培大帝。所以他又多了一个名字。有趣的是，苏拉会这样做，当苏拉是一个如此适应罗马政治的嫉妒和怨恨的人时，他会向庞培让步。现在，听这个的人可能会说，好吧，苏拉这样做是因为他意识到庞培对他是一个威胁，他觉得他别无选择。
Pompey is the rising man. But Sulla doesn't quite see it that way, does he? He has a more nuanced appreciation of Pompey. Sulla, by this point, is not threatened by anyone. I mean, even Pompey. Sulla is undisputed as the ruler of Rome. So I think what's going on, he's not intimidated by Pompey. It's kind of the opposite.
庞培是冉冉升起的人。但苏拉并不完全那样看，不是吗？他对庞培有更细致的评价。到这一点，苏拉没有受到任何人的威胁。我的意思是，即使是庞培。苏拉是无可争议的罗马统治者。所以我认为正在发生的事情是，他并没有被庞培吓倒。这恰恰相反。
I think he sees Pompey as basically, despite all his abilities, as a fundamentally unserious person. So right from the start, that point where Pompey had appeared to Sulla on the road in Campania with all his troops lined up, posing with his quiff and all of that, I think he'd got Pompey's measure. Pompey's vanity, his taste for self-promotion, his kind of relish for the perks of success, really, is telling that Pompey wants a triumph rather than a consulship. He wants the glamour and the swagger. You know, it's the borbils.
我认为他基本上把庞培看作，尽管他有所有的能力，但本质上是一个不严肃的人。所以从一开始，庞培带着他所有的军队在坎帕尼亚的路上出现在苏拉面前，带着他的发型和所有那些东西摆姿势，我想他已经衡量了庞培。庞培的虚荣心，他自我推销的品味，他那种对成功带来的好处的享受，真的，庞培想要凯旋式而不是执政官职位说明了问题。他想要魅力和狂妄。你知道，这是 borbils。
Well, it's not just the borables, but he enjoys being seen to be successful. And so Sulla, who values Pompey as a commander, is happy to allow him, you know, to indulge him on. that front. Whereas Sulla himself, I mean, whatever you want to say about Sulla, I mean, he is a serious player. No one would ever doubt that. He is a military genius as Pompey is. And like Pompey has a great army of loyal legions, but he's much more ruthless than Pompey. And he has been playing a very long game and he has won more spectacularly than anyone in Roman history. But there does remain about Sulla, these kind of paradoxes. that we've been alluding to throughout the series.
好吧，不仅仅是 borbils，但他喜欢被视为成功。所以苏拉，他重视庞培作为一名指挥官，很高兴允许他，你知道，在这方面纵容他。而苏拉自己，我的意思是，无论你想怎么说苏拉，我的意思是，他是一个严肃的参与者。没有人会怀疑这一点。他是一位军事天才，就像庞培一样。而且像庞培一样拥有忠诚军团的伟大军队，但他比庞培更无情。他一直在下一盘很大的棋，他赢得了罗马历史上最壮观的胜利。但苏拉身上确实保留着这些悖论。我们在整个系列中一直在暗示这些。
So, yes, he's a cynic, but he does also have kind of strains of idealism in it. He does believe in Rome. He is a true patriot. And we've said that he's a revolutionary, but he is also a conservative. And so this is why, even as the prescription risks are still going up in the forum, and as the blood is drying on the street, Sulla wants to make sure that he can regularize his position in the Republic. You know, it's important to him that he has constitutional legitimacy. And so he does this not by holding a whole succession of consulships, as a sinner has done,
所以，是的，他是一个愤世嫉俗者，但他身上也确实有某种理想主义的色彩。他确实相信罗马。他是一个真正的爱国者。我们说过他是一个革命者，但他也是一个保守派。所以这就是为什么，即使处决名单仍然贴在广场上，鲜血在街上变干，苏拉也想确保他能使他在共和国的地位正规化。你知道，对他来说，拥有宪法合法性很重要。所以他这样做不是通过像辛纳那样担任一连串的执政官，
but by dusting down a magistracy from the ancient past of Rome. And people who listen to our series on Hannibal may remember that when Hannibal was at his most successful, he just inflicted a particularly devastating defeat on the Romans. and it seemed like he might prove victorious. The Romans had appointed a very distinguished statesman to an office called dictator. And this dictator had been given absolute power over the whole of the Republic without an election. And a six-month limit had been set on this office. But in that six months, he could do whatever he wanted.
而是通过掸掉罗马古代过去的一个地方官职。听过我们关于汉尼拔系列节目的人可能记得，当汉尼拔最成功的时候，他刚刚对罗马人造成了一次特别毁灭性的失败。而且看起来他可能会取得胜利。罗马人任命了一位非常杰出的政治家担任一个叫做独裁官的职位。这位独裁官被赋予了对整个共和国的绝对权力，无需选举。这个职位设定了六个月的限制。但在那六个月里，他可以做任何他想做的事。
And the duty of a dictator is very clear that in a time of danger and disaster, the dictator is called upon to save the republic and then to step down. And this is what Sulla wants. And he intimates this very strongly to the Senate and the Senate duly award him the dictatorship. But Sulla does not want a time limit set on it. He doesn't want to be confined to six months. He wants it to be open-ended. And so again, the Senate, you know, you don't oppose a guy with loads of legions at his back.
独裁官的职责非常明确，即在危险和灾难时期，独裁官被要求拯救共和国，然后下台。这就是苏拉想要的。他向元老院非常强烈地暗示了这一点，元老院也适时地授予了他独裁官职位。但苏拉不想设定时间限制。他不想被限制在六个月内。他希望它是无限期的。所以同样，元老院，你知道，你不会反对一个背后有大量军团的家伙。
they give Sulla an open-ended dictatorship, which is, of course, it's against every constitutional norm. But to reiterate, Sulla's ambition to use his dictatorship to nurse the Republic back to constitutional health, it's not a sham, it's completely genuine. And as dictator, he goes to great efforts to rectify what he sees as the besetting faults of the Republic. And Sulla's diagnosis is an unsurprising one. And it is that the champions of senatorial authority have grown too weak and the popularies, the populists, the people who appeal over the head of the conventional norms of political discourse to the mass of the people beyond that they have gone too far.
他们给了苏拉一个无限期的独裁官职位，这当然是违背了所有的宪法规范。但重申一下，苏拉利用他的独裁官职位来护理共和国恢复宪法健康的野心，这不是虚假的，它是完全真实的。作为独裁官，他竭尽全力纠正他所认为的共和国的困扰。苏拉的诊断并不令人惊讶。那就是元老院权威的捍卫者已经变得太弱了，而平民派，即民粹主义者，那些越过政治话语的传统规范向大众呼吁的人，他们走得太远了。
So he's kind of centrist dadery, I guess, only backed by legions and dictatorial power. Well, you say centrist dattery. You mean you don't see him as an out-and-out reactionary, as ultra-conservative? I think he is an ultra-conservative because that rhythm of those who appeal to the people, those who cast themselves as a conservative, those are the rhythms of the Republic, and they always have been. But I don't think that Sulla sees himself as a reactionary. He sees himself as combating what I think is not an anachronism to describe as populism.
所以他有点像中间派老爸，我想，只是有军团和独裁权力的支持。好吧，你说中间派老爸。你的意思是你不认为他是一个彻底的反动派，作为一个极端的保守派？我认为他是一个极端的保守派，因为那些向人民呼吁的人的节奏，那些将自己塑造成保守派的人，那些是共和国的节奏，而且一直都是。但我不认为苏拉认为自己是一个反动派。他认为自己是在打击我认为描述为民粹主义并不算时代错误的东西。
He is Alistair Campbell. Well, it is, of course, a populism that has been turned very murderous. And he's been the object of it. The fact that he also is murderous, I mean, he's kind of ignoring that. But there clearly are problems. And Sulla, I guess, would say, well, I've earned myself the right to try and apply my prescription. The gods have given me this chance. I'm going to go for it.
他是阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔。好吧，这当然是一种已经变得非常凶残的民粹主义。而且他一直是它的对象。他自己也是凶残的这一事实，我的意思是，他有点忽略了这一点。但显然存在问题。我想苏拉会说，好吧，我已经赢得了尝试应用我的处方的权利。众神给了我这个机会。我要去争取它。
And if you were on Team Sulla, you would look at his record and you would say he wanted to clean up Rome and sort out Roman politics and put it on a more stable footing. and frankly, he did it. No? That's absolutely what they'd say, because he takes a whole raft of measures designed to combat populism. So he tries to restore the Senate, for instance, to help. The Senate has been very badly depleted by the wars and the prescriptions and so on. And Sulla not only restores it, but expands its numbers.
如果你在苏拉团队，你会看他的记录，你会说他想清理罗马，整理罗马政治，并把它放在一个更稳定的基础上。坦率地说，他做到了。不是吗？这绝对是他们会说的，因为他采取了一系列旨在打击民粹主义的措施。例如，他试图恢复元老院，以提供帮助。元老院因战争和处决等原因被严重削弱了。苏拉不仅恢复了它，还扩大了它的人数。
So it had been 300 before the Civil War. Sulla raises its number to 600. And he makes sure, interestingly, to include members of the numbers of the war. the Italian elites. So this is a kind of an olive branch to the Italians who have always regarded Sulla as their enemy. He's basically saying, you know, let bygones, be bygones. You are Romans now. Come into the Senate. Help us heal the wounds of our city and of Italy. He also passes laws that are very obviously influenced by events of the past few years. So he passes a law that requires a consul to wait an absolute minimum of 10 years before he can run for the consulship
所以内战前是300人。苏拉将其人数增加到600人。有趣的是，他确保包括了战争的成员。意大利精英。所以这是一种对意大利人的橄榄枝，他们一直把苏拉视为他们的敌人。他基本上是在说，你知道，让过去的事情过去吧。你们现在是罗马人了。进入元老院。帮助我们治愈我们城市和意大利的伤口。他还通过了一些显然受到过去几年事件影响的法律。所以他通过了一项法律，要求执政官在能够再次竞选执政官之前必须等待至少10年
again. So that's obviously targeted at people like Marius, at people like sinner. Right. He legally regulates the age at which ambitious young nobleses can run for magistracies. So 30 is set by law as the minimum age that someone can run for a junior magistracy. And you cannot become a consul before the age of 40 again by law. This has previously been founded on tradition. Sulla is basically saying we can't rely on tradition anymore. It has to be prescriptive.
。所以这显然是针对像马略、像辛纳这样的人。对。他在法律上规定了雄心勃勃的年轻贵族可以竞选地方官职的年龄。所以法律规定30岁是某人可以竞选初级地方官职的最低年龄。而且法律规定你不能在40岁之前成为执政官。这以前是基于传统的。苏拉基本上是在说我们不能再依赖传统了。它必须是规定性的。
And of course, the magistracy that he really hates, because it has been weaponized against him so repeatedly is the tribunate. And he goes out of his way to emasculate the tribunate. So he forbids them to propose bills. And remember that it was a bill that had been proposed by a tribune that had allowed Marius to try and strip him of his command in 88. BC. They are also, this is a very cunning move, anyone who becomes a tribune is then banned from running for further magistracies. So you're never going to do it, yeah. No, no, it's the tribune that becomes a dead end. And Sulla's aim is very transparently to make sure that never again will there be a Marius, a sinner, a Marius Jr. in Roman political life. And you can see
当然，他真正痛恨的地方官职，因为它被如此反复地用作对付他的武器，就是保民官。他竭尽全力阉割保民官。所以他禁止他们提出法案。记住，正是由保民官提出的法案允许马略在公元前88年试图剥夺他的指挥权。他们也是，这是一个非常狡猾的举动，任何成为保民官的人随后都被禁止竞选进一步的地方官职。所以你永远不会这样做，是的。不，不，保民官变成了一个死胡同。苏拉的目标非常透明，即确保罗马政治生活中再也不会有马略、辛纳、小马略。你可以看到
exactly, he's trying to block off all the avenues that they had taken to what Sulla sees as rank populism and illegality. And it takes him two years to perform this surgery on the Republic. And then after two years, Sulla feels that he has succeeded, that the Republic is cured. And one morning to everyone's absolute astonishment, he appears one day in the forum and he doesn't have the 24 lictors that he's been going around with in his role as dictator. Remember, the consul has 12 lictors. Sulla's been going around with 24. But now this morning, They've all gone. And it's a stunning moment because the man who's been responsible for the deaths of more Romans
确切地说，他试图封锁他们所采取的所有通往苏拉所认为的等级民粹主义和非法性的途径。他花了两年时间对共和国进行这种手术。然后两年后，苏拉觉得他成功了，共和国被治愈了。一天早上，令所有人绝对震惊的是，他有一天出现在广场上，他没有他在担任独裁官角色时一直带着的24名侍从。记住，执政官有12名侍从。苏拉一直带着24名。但现在这个早上，他们都不见了。这是一个令人震惊的时刻，因为那个对死亡负责的罗马人比
than anyone else in the history of the Republic has simply laid his dictatorship aside and become a completely private citizen. He has no office at all. Whoa. And he had done this, so to quote Aryan, the historian of this period, fearing neither his enemies at home nor the exiles abroad. Such was the extent of his daring and his good luck. So Sulla's in his late 50s at this point, he could have stayed.
共和国历史上任何其他人都多的人，已经简单地放弃了他的独裁官职位，成为一个完全的私人公民。他根本没有任何职位。哇。他这样做，引用这一时期的历史学家阿里安的话，既不惧怕国内的敌人，也不惧怕国外的流亡者。这就是他胆量和好运的程度。所以苏拉此时已是50多岁，他本可以留下来。
John, he could have thought, well, I'll be dictated till the end of my days, but he seems diacletian style or something. He's given up his power and gone into retirement. How does he think he can get away with this? That parallel. Yeah. You know who at the end of the 18th century, Sulla is often compared to is George Washington.
约翰，他本可以想，好吧，我会一直独裁到我生命的尽头，但他看起来像戴克里先风格之类的。他放弃了他的权力并退休了。他怎么认为他能逃脱惩罚？那个平行。是的。你知道在18世纪末，苏拉经常被比作乔治·华盛顿。
So, because George Washington had laid down the presidency as Sulla had laid down the dictatorship. Two massive differences, though. Yeah, I agree. Sulla has his own teeth. Seller has all his own teeth. And a night out with Sulla would be a tremendous laugh. And a night out with George Washington would be purgatory. I think a night out with Sulla would be a tremendous laugh because he has an absolutely
所以，因为乔治·华盛顿像苏拉放弃独裁官职位一样放弃了总统职位。不过，有两个巨大的区别。是的，我同意。苏拉有他自己的牙齿。苏拉有他所有的牙齿。和苏拉出去玩会是一个巨大的笑话。而和乔治·华盛顿出去玩会是炼狱。我认为和苏拉出去玩会是一个巨大的笑话，因为他有一个绝对
brilliant retirement. How is he able to enjoy his retirement? I mean, he has all these enemies. I think in part it's because he chooses to spend a lot of time on the Bay of Naples where he is surrounded by his loyal veterans. And the reason for this is that Sulla has been a plight of. planting colonies, which are settlements of Romans and particularly discharged soldiers, where the Italian rebels had been based.
辉煌的退休生活。他怎么能享受他的退休生活？我的意思是，他有这么多敌人。我认为部分原因是，他选择花很多时间在那不勒斯湾，在那里他被他忠诚的退伍军人所包围。原因是苏拉一直在种植殖民地，这是罗马人和特别是退伍士兵的定居点，在意大利叛军曾经驻扎的地方。
So one of these colonies is founded at Pompeii, which Sulla had stormed back in 89. And it's from this point onwards really that Pompeii comes to rank as a Roman town. And the same fate is visited on Nola, which actually only finally surrendered in 80 BC. So that is after Sulla had laid down his dictatorship. So that really is the last holdout. So Sulla plants a colony there, and he's ever a man for a vindictive gesture. And so he renames Nola Colonia Phelix after himself.
所以其中一个殖民地是在庞贝建立的，苏拉在公元前89年曾攻占过那里。从这一点开始，庞贝确实开始被列为罗马城镇。同样的命运也降临在诺拉，它实际上直到公元前80年才最终投降。所以那是在苏拉放弃他的独裁官职位之后。所以那确实是最后的据点。所以苏拉在那里种植了一个殖民地，他一直是一个喜欢报复性姿态的人。所以他以自己的名字将诺拉重新命名为 Colonia Phelix。
Nice. Which, you know, such a triumph. And where is he? What's he doing? Well, of course, I mean, he's had his pick of beachside villas. He's got a lot of real estate along the Neapolitan coast. And his main villa is between Naples and Puteoli, the Great Port. And he has such a lovely time.
不错。这，你知道，真是一个胜利。他在哪里？他在做什么？好吧，当然，我的意思是，他可以选择海滩别墅。他在那不勒斯海岸有很多房地产。他的主要别墅在那不勒斯和伟大的港口普特奥利之间。他玩得很开心。
So he throws himself into the pleasures of the Bay of Naples, the oysters, the spas, the yacht parties, all of that. Good. Sounds brilliant. As Marius had done, he has massive drinking bouts. These go on for days and days and days. And he hangs out with all his old mates. from his bohemian days. So people who listened to our first episode may remember that he loved a stand-up comic. He loved an actor. He loved a cortisan and he loved a drag queen. And he gets all
所以他投身于那不勒斯湾的乐趣，牡蛎、水疗中心、游艇派对，所有这些。好。听起来很棒。正如马略所做的那样，他有大量的饮酒狂欢。这些持续了几天又几天。他和所有的老朋友一起玩。从他波西米亚时代开始。所以听过我们第一集的人可能记得他喜欢脱口秀喜剧演员。他喜欢演员。他喜欢交际花，他喜欢变装皇后。他把所有
of these old friends of his down to party. So it's commented of one particular of these friends, Matrobius, who was a drag queen. The Matrobius had seen better days, but Sulla never ceased to insist that he was in love with him all the same. And so he's there with his drag queens and the stand-up comics, necking wine, it's having great time. He has had the best time, I think, of anyone we've ever done on the rest of history, because he's ticked two, very difficult to tick boxes. One, he's in retirement on the, basically, the Bay of Naples, that dream honeymoon destination, stuffing himself with oysters at a ripe old age
这些他的老朋友都叫来聚会。所以有人评论他的一位特别的朋友，马特罗比乌斯，他是一位变装皇后。马特罗比乌斯已经过了鼎盛时期，但苏拉从未停止坚持说他仍然爱着他。所以他和他的变装皇后以及脱口秀喜剧演员在那里，狂饮葡萄酒，玩得很开心。我认为他度过了我们在《The Rest is history》中做过的任何人中最美好的时光，因为他勾选了两个非常难勾选的框。第一，他在那不勒斯湾退休，基本上是那个梦想中的蜜月目的地，在成熟的年纪大吃牡蛎
with drag queens and actors and having a great laugh. And secondly, they don't forget, he's still got the heads of his enemies. completely. So that's brilliant. The jokes the stand-up comedians make with those props to hand. I mean, they'd be tremendous. You can do some fantastic routines with the severed heads of your adversaries. You could play football, rugby, whatever. God almighty, I'm so envious. I'm so so envious. This actually doesn't last for very long, though, does it? That's the downside. No, he, so he dies in 78 BC. So not, you know, just kind of a couple of years after, really. Yeah, but what a way to bow out. And unsurprisingly, he seems to have died of liver failure. Right. That seems to be the likeliest explanation for what kills him. And when he's dead, there are at this point people in Rome who find their courage and who say, you know, actually, I think we should damn his memory.
和变装皇后以及演员在一起，玩得很开心。第二，别忘了，他仍然有他敌人的头颅。完全是。所以这太棒了。脱口秀喜剧演员用那些手头的道具开的玩笑。我的意思是，他们会很棒。你可以用你对手的断头做一些精彩的表演。你可以踢足球、橄榄球，随便什么。天哪，我太羡慕了。我太、太羡慕了。这实际上并没有持续很长时间，不是吗？那是缺点。不，他，所以他在公元前78年去世了。所以不是，你知道，只是几年之后，真的。是的，但这是一个多么好的谢幕方式。不出所料，他似乎死于肝功能衰竭。对。这似乎是对杀死他的原因最可能的解释。当他死后，此时罗马有人找到了他们的勇气，他们说，你知道，实际上，我认为我们应该诅咒他的记忆。
And at the very least, we should not give him any public funerary honours. You know, he was a terrible man. But again, this is an echo of what happens when Augustine. dies, Sulla's veterans descend on his villa and they escort his body back to Rome out onto the campus marches where great state funerals are held. And obviously there is no one in Rome to oppose this band of veterans. And they build a huge pyre for Sulla and they put the body on it. And as they lay it, a great wind comes gusting across the campus and it whips the flames into
至少，我们不应该给他任何公共葬礼荣誉。你知道，他是一个可怕的人。但同样，这是奥古斯都去世时发生的事情的回声。苏拉的退伍军人降临到他的别墅，他们护送他的尸体回到罗马，来到马尔斯广场，在那里举行了盛大的国葬。显然，罗马没有人反对这群退伍军人。他们为苏拉建造了一个巨大的柴堆，并把尸体放在上面。当他们放下它时，一阵大风吹过广场，它把火焰卷成了
life and the body is consumed and then the moment it's been consumed, it starts to rain. And everyone says, oh, this proves it. Sulla is lucky. He's been lucky absolutely to the end. But I guess the question that listeners may be asking themselves is, does that luck hold in the years and the decades that follow his death? Have his reforms worked? Has the surgery that he's performed on the Republic?
生命和躯体被消耗殆尽，就在消耗殆尽的那一刻，天开始下雨了。每个人都说，哦，这证明了这一点。苏拉是幸运的。他一直幸运到了最后。但我猜听众们可能在问自己一个问题，这种好运在他死后的岁月和几十年里还能持续吗？他的改革奏效了吗？他为共和国所做的手术成功了吗？
Has it proven successful? Has he managed to restore the Republic back to a full and enduring health, or is the future darker? Has Sulla set an example of what any general in the future with an army at his back might achieve, given sufficient daring, given sufficient genius? And does the future belong perhaps not to a republic at all, but to a form of autocracy? Right. I want to ask you two questions about that. So number one, everybody listened to this podcast knows. Well, a lot of people listen to this podcast, anyone will know that in the long run, the Roman Republic does not endure and becomes an empire.
它被证明成功了吗？他是否成功地让共和国恢复了全面而持久的健康，还是未来更加黑暗？苏拉是否为未来任何一位背后有军队支持的将军树立了一个榜样，只要有足够的胆量，有足够的天才，就能实现什么？未来属于的可能根本不是共和国，而是一种独裁形式？对。我想就此问你两个问题。第一，听这个播客的每个人都知道。好吧，很多人听这个播客，任何人都知道，从长远来看，罗马共和国并没有持续下去，而是变成了一个帝国。
Who do you think is more important in the death of the Roman Republic, Marius or Sulla? Sulla. because Marius, he's a brilliant political operator, but he's not as pitiless in his cynicism as Sulla is. And Sulla, by leading his troops on Rome, sets an example that is properly tabo-busting. So what had once been unthinkable is now lurking at the back of basically every Roman general's mind. So Cicero, who we will be doing a bonus of. with Catherine Edwards, he's written a great biography of him, you know, the famous orator of Rome, he wrote a letter to a friend in which he just said Sulla could do it, why can't I?
你认为在罗马共和国的灭亡中，谁更重要，马略还是苏拉？苏拉。因为马略，他是一位杰出的政治操盘手，但他不像苏拉那样冷酷无情。而苏拉通过率军攻打罗马，树立了一个真正打破禁忌的榜样。所以，曾经不可想象的事情现在潜伏在几乎每一位罗马将军的脑海深处。所以西塞罗，我们将和凯瑟琳·爱德华兹一起做一期关于他的特别节目，她写了一本关于他的伟大传记，你知道，那位著名的罗马演说家，他写信给一位朋友说，苏拉能做到，为什么我不能？
This is what they will be pondering. Yeah. You know, he's put his finger on exactly the issue, that once a taboo's broken, you know, it's very difficult to restore it. Lally, is perfectly into my second question. We've already alluded to the similarities between Sulla and a much better known Roman. the man who does actually bury the Republic and become the first Roman emperor, which is Octavian, who becomes Augustus.
这就是他们将要思考的问题。是的。你知道，他准确地指出了问题所在，一旦禁忌被打破，你知道，就很难恢复了。拉利，这完全符合我的第二个问题。我们已经提到了苏拉和一位更著名的罗马人之间的相似之处。那个真正埋葬了共和国并成为第一位罗马皇帝的人，就是屋大维，也就是后来的奥古斯都。
What's the difference between Sulla and Octavian? Why didn't Sulla become the first Roman emperor? Why didn't he found a dynasty and destroy the Republic completely? Because he's a conservative, because even though he's the man who has led an army for the first time against Rome, he admires and respects the constitutional norms, and he wants to see them upheld. You mention Octavian, who of course in due course will become Augustus and establish the autocracy of the Caesars that will endure for centuries and centuries and centuries. The person you've missed out is Julius Caesar, and Julius Caesar is very much embroiled in the
苏拉和屋大维有什么区别？为什么苏拉没有成为第一位罗马皇帝？为什么他没有建立一个王朝并彻底摧毁共和国？因为他是一个保守派，因为即使他是第一个率军攻打罗马的人，他也钦佩并尊重宪法规范，并希望看到它们得到维护。你提到了屋大维，他当然会在适当的时候成为奥古斯都，并建立起将持续几个世纪又几个世纪的凯撒独裁统治。你漏掉的人是尤利乌斯·凯撒，而尤利乌斯·凯撒非常卷入了
aftermath of the conflict between Marius and Sulla, because Julius Caesar, we've mentioned this, is by marriage, the nephew of Marius. And he is prescribed and very, very narrowly avoids being killed, gets apart. from Sulla, and Sulla says, you know, there is a lot of Marius in this young man. We have to be careful. But actually, when Caesar himself marches on Rome becomes a dictator, as Sulla had done, Caesar said that Sulla had been a fool because he had laid down his dictatorship. Caesar, of course, does not lay down his dictatorship and ends up murdered. Yeah.
马略和苏拉冲突的余波中，因为尤利乌斯·凯撒，我们提到过，按婚姻关系算，是马略的侄子。他被列入公敌名单，非常非常惊险地避免了被杀，从苏拉那里逃脱了。苏拉说，你知道，这个年轻人身上有很多马略的影子。我们必须小心。但实际上，当凯撒本人进军罗马成为独裁者时，就像苏拉所做的那样，凯撒说苏拉是个傻瓜，因为他放弃了独裁统治。当然，凯撒并没有放弃他的独裁统治，最终被谋杀了。是的。
But the lessons that Caesar chooses to draw from the war between Maris and Sulla, even though himself is a Merion, he chooses to look to Sulla as the most significant player in that conflict. Well, that's the sublime irony of the whole thing, isn't it? That a man who was dedicated to the principles of conservatism shows his successes the way to demolish the structures, the institutions in some ways for which he was fighting. Anyway, an absolutely fascinating and thrilling series. And as you rightly say, not quite over, because for Restis History club members. There is a bonus to come about Cicero, so a generation later, and what he made of Marius and Sulla. And that is out this week and it's out with the brilliant Catherine Edwards.
但凯撒选择从马略和苏拉的战争中吸取的教训，尽管他自己是马略派，但他选择将苏拉视为那场冲突中最重要的人物。嗯，这就是整件事最绝妙的讽刺，不是吗？一个致力于保守主义原则的人，向他的继任者展示了如何拆除他所奋斗的那些结构和制度。总之，这是一个绝对迷人且激动人心的系列。正如你所说，还没有完全结束，因为对于“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员来说。还有一个关于西塞罗的特别节目，也就是一代人之后，以及他对马略和苏拉的看法。这期节目本周播出，由杰出的凯瑟琳·爱德华兹主持。
And if you want to listen to that and you're not a member of the club, you can of course go to the rest ishistory.com and sign up. And you should, of course, whether you want to join the club or not, sign up to our amazing newsletter, which comes every week and is completely free. So, Tom, thank you very much for that. That was absolutely riveting. Bye, bye, everybody. Bye-bye. The Prime Minister, you've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context.
如果你想听那个节目，而你又不是俱乐部成员，你当然可以去therestishistory.com注册。当然，无论你想不想加入俱乐部，你都应该注册我们很棒的时事通讯，它每周都会发布，而且完全免费。所以，汤姆，非常感谢你。那真是太引人入胜了。再见，大家。再见。首相，你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。
All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today, disseminated into an operation order, or Fraggo. A Fraggo that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. News from Gullheimer. Who is going to be able to pull this off? You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuff. An audio drama journey like no other.
今天所有相关的背景都将构建成一个框架，分发成作战命令或Fraggo。一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的Fraggo。是的。来自古尔海默的消息。谁能完成这个任务？你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士。一段独一无二的广播剧旅程。
Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action thriller. We have two-time-friendly key-I-e. Where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。这是一部技术严谨的、地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有两次获得英国电影学院奖的演员。英国打出了最强的一张牌。他是最棒的。对抗它最强大的敌人。现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。